so
[Music]
this immediate existence is at the same
time not solely and simply immediate
consciousness but is religious
consciousness
the immediacy has inseparably the
meaning not only of a self-consciousness
that immediately is
but also of the supreme being as an
absolute essence in pure thought or
absolute being
what we are conscious of in our notion
that is that being his essence is what
the religious consciousness is also
conscious of this unity of being an
essence of thought which is immediately
existence
is both the thought of this religious
consciousness or its mediated knowledge
and equally its immediate knowledge for
this unity of being and thought is
self-consciousness and is itself
immediately present or the thought unity
has at the same time this existential
shape of what it is
here therefore god is revealed as he is
he is immediately present as he is in
himself that is he is immediately
present as spirit
god is attainable in pure speculative
knowledge alone and is only in that
knowledge and is only that knowledge
itself for he is spirit
and this speculative knowledge is the
knowledge of the revealed religion
speculative knowledge knows god as
thought or pure essence and knows this
thought as simple being and as existence
and existence as the negativity of
itself
hence as self as the self that is at the
same time this individual and also the
universal self
it is precisely this that the revealed
religion knows the hopes and
expectations of the world up till now
had pressed forward solely to this
revelation to behold what absolute being
is and in it to find itself the joy of
beholding itself in absolute being
enters self-consciousness and seizes the
whole world for it is spirit it is the
simple movement of those pure moments
which expresses just this that only when
absolute being is beheld as an immediate
self-consciousness is it known as spirit
paragraph
761 is you might say an exciting one
there's a lot going on and being
referenced or being
mentioned here being worked through in
this longish paragraph we might think
for example
of these
in the heart of it being an essence and
thought and existence and the
identifications that are taking place
with some sort of immediacy and yet also
immediacy we could think of the
invocation of speculative knowledge
right which is actually right there
transliterated in the german speculative
right and you know this is revealing to
us what the religious consciousness or
self-consciousness is and we have
god being revealed as what god is and
for those who are fans of hegel and his
approach you'll be no doubt happy to
find out that god is indeed spirit or
geist right so there's a lot happening
here i actually want to jump to the
final bits of this paragraph to
highlight something
right at the start
that otherwise might get
dropped out or overlooked and it has to
do with affectivity with
feelings with
desires with uh what we can call our
emotional
side
so he says this is right after he says
it is precisely this
that the revealed religion knows then he
talks about hopes right hope is
a passion it's also got cognitive
aspects to it but hope is something very
important hofnong in this right and the
expectations okay expectation is more of
a action thing although it's uh not
taking action just remaining in action
and
right the hopes and expectations of the
world
up till now had pressed forward solely
to this revelation and we'll talk about
what that revelation is and then we have
another key term here
the joy
of beholding itself in absolute being
enters self-consciousness and seizes the
whole
world now joy what is joy floyda right a
happiness a feeling of things being all
right being positive having attained to
something and there's actually that that
term attaining erratical is coming up in
terms of what speculative knowledge does
and speculative knowledge is not going
to be the kind of musty abstract thing
that we might be worried about it being
so these emotions of hoping of
this this comportment of waiting and
this feeling of joy
are a central part of what is going on
here we don't want to lose sight of that
and we could contrast this to what was
going on in and i've talked about this
many times so you might be getting a
little bit tired of hearing it but it's
it's absolutely important that we do
talk about it uh you know the unhappy
consciousness right the own
side um
it doesn't enjoy the these things i mean
it hopes but it's hopes are disappointed
it's waiting but it's also taking action
it doesn't have
joy
or happiness glucklich that's why it's
the unhappy consciousness we have
attained to something
new and there's a
outpouring
and a preparation you might say
in terms of our affective life at this
point
so let's
go on and look at the text
he says this immediate
existence is at the same time not solely
and simply immediate
consciousness but is religious
consciousness
so
two things we we need to say there the
first thing is okay
this
consciousness like he just said uh is
not
is at the same time not just immediate
consciousness right this immediate
existence but is religious religiosis
consciousness and as it's going to turn
out it is religious
consciousness and self-consciousness
once again think back to the very
beginning of the religion section
when we were talking much more in
general before we got into nature
religion and religion as art and now
revealed religion
think about the fact that religion by
itself for hegel was already figured as
something that was going to be bringing
together
consciousness and self-consciousness in
a new way which takes the previous
developed four paths up until this time
consciousness self-consciousness
reason and spirit and brings them
together and transforms them this is auf
hebong this is sublation right
so that's important
this word immediate
for english speakers
this can be a bit misleading
but
you know what what else should we have
picked
unmediated
not
mediated um that's a little bit more
cumbersome but it's a little bit closer
to you know one metal bar right it's not
mediated it's not mediating itself it is
right there
raw for us
as you know the phenomenologist
observing what's going on and for that
consciousness it has
certainty
so immediate existence is uh both
immediate consciousness but is also
religious consciousness now existence
design something we're going to see
coming up here
a little bit later
he goes on and he says
the immediacy so what's presenting
itself is completely immediate
unmediated
has
also
the meaning the badoitong right it it is
suggesting to us not only of a
self-consciousness so now we're going
it's not just a consciousness it's also
a self-consciousness the self is
thinking about itself in relation to its
object and it is also thinking about
itself in relation to others and to we
might say a capital o other here as well
so it has the meaning not only of the
self-consciousness that immediately is
but also
of the supreme being
as an absolute essence
in pure thought or
absolute being so we're bringing
together a couple different things right
supreme being
is also absolute invasions something
that we've been encountering in the past
several paragraphs the
uh absolute essence the absolute
important thing the thing that is uh at
the center
right and he says now something really
interesting so we've got
self-consciousness we've got absolute
being or supreme being
what we are conscious of
now who's the we there
it's us
reading hegel it's hegel talking to his
contemporaries it's also all those
people
back in history when this revelation is
taking place who don't quite fully
understand what's going on but are
proceeding along the path of the spirit
along the path of the dialectic and
these things are unfolding for them
he says in our notion in our concept in
our begith right how we are taking these
things in
as a
whole and making
sense of them not just through
representation or feeling at this point
in time
or you know bear dogmas or simple
practices but it's something that is
coherent
something that is connected and we might
even say to prefigure a little bit
something that is united
so he goes on and he says
what we are conscious of now notice this
not in the notion or its notion
our notion right we are conscious we
in our notion
we're in a certain sense being
transported back to this important time
when revelation is taking place
what is the what are we conscious of
that being is essence
he says this is what the religious
consciousness is also conscious of being
is essence and
this is where it gets a little you know
tricky translating wise because
sometimes miller actually translates
these and as being but the the what
we've got right here is being
sein right
so
being as such
now is this like you know
any old being no this is this is gonna
be a little bit more determinate and
then we have essence essences you might
say a
closing in on a certain kind of being
that also reveals to us the the what
matters in being i understand this
sounds a little heideggerian but i think
that
is entirely warranted here so we have a
unity
an einheit
a oneness right a unity of being and
thought this unity of being in thought
is
self-consciousness
right so we have a unity of being in
essence
of thought which is immediately
existence he says
and now this is very interesting
because up until this point in time it's
all been more or less unmediated right i
mean you could say well these things are
being mediated through each other
implicitly but hegel's not laying that
on the table then he says that
this unity is both the thought of this
religious consciousness or its mediated
knowledge
and equally is it's immediate knowledge
so we've got mediated knowledge
knowledge through something else and
immediate knowledge wouldn't mental bar
nothing is standing in the way and these
are
shall we say
mediated with each other i mean here's
the thing you know nothing is ever
totally unmediated or immediate for long
in the hegelian dialectic is it you know
we always find out there's mediation the
immediate is what it is in relation to
the
the the the immediate is what it is in
relation to the immediate so it is
mediated right through
the the it's opposite the the mediated
and so
this is not completely
immediate it involves mediation
so he goes on he says this unity of
being
sign and thought
that's self-consciousness
and is itself immediately present
or
this is a really interesting phrase the
thought unity the now this is very
important too right
being
is a unity in this case right it's a
unity of being with essence and
existence and thought
and
what's really essential here well this
unity
thought configure to itself thought can
grasp this unity however you know dimly
it does so
maybe not entirely worked out thought is
kind of special here compared to being
essence and existence in that it grasps
this unity
and so he goes on and he says um
this thought unity has at the same time
and here's where miller puts into this
bracketing existential shape of what it
is
why is he putting this existential
bracketing in here because the word da
is there right da ist is in this
paragraph or in this passage this
sentence and so miller wants to kind of
reflect that
by referencing existence dazn
which is involved with thought
the thinking
being
is at the same time an existing being
and it thinks about what exists not just
what has essence not just what has being
or is being
but what is there what is present to us
in the world
so he goes on
and he says that
here therefore now we have an important
shift
god
is revealed
as he is now this revealed
in the german right um orphan bar
it's not saying you know god reveals
himself it's not saying something is
revealing god
god just is this open bar it's a it's a
predicate of that subject of god
god
reveals
you could say as
revealed
that isn't a little bit too tricky as
what he is not just as you know say oh
moses go let the people out of egypt i
mean moses is smart enough if we want to
go back and think about the exodus story
to say
what should i say that you are what's
your name a crazy deity that's you know
burning a bush there and talking to me
and telling me i'm going to do this wild
thing i'm not a good speaker you want me
to go back to egypt where i killed a man
and i could be killed for that
um you got this you know whole
interesting thing going on who are you
and god says instead of saying well
i am and then naming something god says
what god is
i am that and that i am you know
this complex tricky phrase that
references being particularly in the the
greek translation translation the
septuagint right so god is revealed as
what he is and what is it that god is
he says he is immediately present as he
is
in himself on zeke he is immediately
present how
spirit
geist
mind if you like
what it is that the entire phenomenology
is about it this is the phenomenology of
geist
so god is revealing what geist is and
what he is and how we
are connected
to that
so now here we get to this interesting
point
god is attainable
god can be attained
we can get to god in in an adequate way
in pure speculative knowledge alone and
is
only in that knowledge and is only that
knowledge itself so there's there's a
lot going on in there
there's different modes of you know
reaching god conceiving of god and we've
seen many of them throughout other
sections of the phenomenology now we're
being given a claim here that it's only
through
speculative knowledge so we should think
for a minute what is speculative
knowledge
and
you know it's tempting at first to say
well you know we know that there's like
speculative or you know like pure
philosophy and then there's practical
philosophy and maybe there's some other
stuff on the side like you know
aesthetics or things like that we can
adopt this this paradigm that comes to
us not just from kant but also from
earlier philosophers actually going all
the way back you might say to aristotle
who distinguished between you know
theoretical and practical philosophy
they have different aims there's
different kinds of truth right is that
what hegel means
well
it's hard to say that
because of something that he says
immediately after that would really
throw a monkey wrench into that
he says that
this speculative knowledge
is the knowledge
of the revealed religion
well what does that mean so this is all
viscense this is all knowledge in
nonsense not knowledge by acquaintance
but like actually knowing things and
presumably
there might be some representation some
foreshtelling involved in it right but
presumably it's
notional or conceptual
knowledge it is the knowledge within the
notion particularly given that hegel has
told us
that just just earlier
right that god is attainable in pure
speculative knowledge
and is only in that knowledge and is
only that knowledge itself so the
knowledge
the object of the knowledge is also the
knowledge so what do we what do we have
here speculative must be understood
in a different way and here i think the
contrast between
mediatedness and immediacy could be
helpful to read in
so as speculative knowledge we're
talking about i would say here
the concept the concept of god something
that we
know
by
you know bringing god in a certain way
into our own little bit of spirit we
know god is spirit within ourselves is
something transcending ourselves
something that we can also like bring
back in to
ourselves and our knowledge so that's
the mediated side and then we have
knowledge of revealed religion
which again we're gonna have to clarify
right
at least in some sense
orphan borrowing revelation is a boom
here you go this is something that you
don't have to worry about its origin at
this point in time just focus on the
content see what's actually there
because it's you know a text it's an
experience it's a person it's whatever
it's going to be could even be something
negative that is going to work on you
like uh very often parables can can be
you know
jesus taught through parables and
sometimes they actually explain them to
his followers who are like what the hell
is that that about right
so
speculative knowledge to go back to this
god is
a spirit
and this speculative knowledge
is how we attain god
and god
is
only that knowledge itself because he's
spirit so when we are figuring out what
god is
in speculative knowledge which is a lot
of work
god is there with us
not just as an object of knowledge not
just as something that's being figured
but and this is going to sound a little
you know christian platonist right god
is not a being god is
this very process by which we're
conceptualizing god
let's let's go on a little bit more so
he tells us that
speculative knowledge is the knowledge
of the revealed religion what does that
mean at this point so he says
speculative knowledge knows god as
thought right or pure essence and knows
this thought as simple being and as
existence
all of these are involved being thought
essence existence and
there's something special about
existence existence
as the negativity of itself
right the negativity of existence but
also the negativity of these other
things that it is and isn't
and what does this yield us
negativity of the self is the self the
zelpst
and this self
takes on two different sides
in this part of revealed religion
he says that the self that is at the
same time
this individual now
in this individual is not actually there
it's just i mean miller is reading this
in it's
diesis could it be this individual it
makes sense that it would be because
hegel's been talking about individuality
but it's also the universal algae minus
it's both at the same time it is the
individual who is in some respect a
universal and we're lucky enough to be
at the point in time where the human
being has developed to be able to grasp
this
and he says this is precisely
what the revealed religion knows
that god is
something not just universal not just
all this metaphysical stuff
but
someone who encounters us who comes
forward into
existence the existence that we live
and has something to to tell us
something to say to us here's where we
get to the part that i brought up
earlier about these aff activities it is
precisely this that the revealed
religion knows the hopes and
expectations
of the world
up till now had pressed forward solely
to this revelation
to behold what absolute being is and in
it to find itself three really important
things going on in that sentence right
hopes and expectations of who
the speculative you know uh knower yes
but not just the speculative knower not
just the people in that point in time
everybody
the whole world
whether they realize they're not whether
they're fortunate enough to get this
revelation
hegel thinks that
what is happening here is a very
important part of world history the
development of consciousness so that's
one important point
to behold what absolute being is so
there have been a lot of
attempts to figure out what absolute
being is um in a variety of different
ways you could think of everything that
was happening in the reasons section
where you know we're trying to figure
out this world and where we fit in it
and what human beings are and you know
all the way to like laws of of thought
and then you know into
other things that that you know are
connected with the
the ethical substance you know and also
the xhaka zelps and then we get into the
spirit section and all of this has been
tending to try to figure out what what
is absolute being right what is the
whole what is most important and again
you know we could go back to this uh
quaternity being what is the absolute
being what is the essence of it what how
can we think of it and does it actually
enter into existence or are we just a
bunch of poor slobs down here
you know outside of the the place where
essence is or true being is condemned to
some place that doesn't really matter no
it enters into
existence so the hopes and expectations
of the world to behold what absolute
being is
third important thing
in it
to find itself
we find ourselves
in god
we find ourselves in the absolute being
which means
that
to the degree that we're not focused on
that we're actually piddling around with
all sorts of stuff that isn't really at
the center of things
and we're not truly knowing ourself
except through absolute being
so he goes on and he says there's a joy
of beholding itself
in absolute being which enters
self-consciousness
and seizes the whole world now the whole
world that might be a little ambitious
if we're talking about christianity
obviously uh it didn't seize the whole
world all at once
um
but you know eventually it extends
itself maybe you could say hegel's world
is a little bit impoverished i mean we
know about hegel thinking that the
center of things is really in first in
greece and then in roman than in europe
right and that other places aren't quite
so important but you know
put that aside for the moment the joy of
beholding itself an absolute being
why it is spirit it is the simple
movement of those pure moments which
expresses just this
only when absolute being is beheld as an
immediate unmediated own mittelbar
self-consciousness is it known
as spirit so we we have different other
ways we could have known absolute being
you know again think about the temple
and the statuary and the the epic and
you know all these other god is light
all those are
fine as developmental steps for hegel
what we really want to encounter is a
self-consciousness
somebody that we can connect and relate
ourselves to and so all of this has been
leading the religious self-consciousness
engages with the individual who is also
a universal and in the process
gets to know itself
not just the religious object not just
the god
but gets to know itself and god in
spirit in
geist
you